hey martin what are you doing hey grant
we get a lot of questions about whether
one should use cloud functions
or cloud run uh when should one use
which one
yeah let's show some examples
sounds great
[Music]
creator watch has come to us and ask
should they use cloud functions
or cloudrun for their service they build
wildlife cameras so you can put one of
the cameras in your backyard or out in
the forest
and whenever an animal passes in front
of the camera it takes a picture and
uploads it to the cloud
now that picture those pictures uploaded
to the cloud they want
machine learning to work on those
pictures identify what species of
animals
were uh that were in the pictures and
then insert these
sightings into a firestore database
so uh grant should they use cloud
functions or cloud run what do you think
well looking at the selection grid i
mean they
they probably should use cloud functions
i mean they
they could use cloud run but it requires
a little bit more configuration
and with sending a google cloud storage
event
to pub sub to cloud run it's a little
bit more complicated
where cloud functions does this
automatically
got it uh what would the code look like
for this
yeah let's go dive into vs cad yeah so
here's the code for the function that
analyzes the image
now grant what happens here in the
beginning of the function
yeah so we're going to set up the vision
api
and the firestore api and then we're
going to go
and track a couple of the animals uh
things you might see in your backyard
like raccoons alpacas
dogs geckos wow your backyard is a lot
more exotic than mine grant
and then um we'll go and define a
function
uh so this is triggered whenever a cloud
storage bucket
uh there's a change there
oh so we as developers don't call this
function
google cloud platform calls it is that
right
yep uh it detects the event
automatically and calls this function
when and the event being so whenever a
new file is uploaded
to this particular bucket okay so that
is a camera out there in the field
uploads uh an image got it and then what
what does this function do with the
image so then with the
image event it goes and
uh uses the cloud vision api against
that file
and with the result it returns
a json object with a bunch of different
labels
of what it finds in the image
so it could be things that aren't
animals but we only really care about
the animals
oh that's right it could be like a fence
or lawn furniture
or things like that but yeah it seems
like we extract
car right we extract only the animal
tags here
cool and then it looks like down on line
30 we do something with that extracted
animal tag
yep and so then we check if it's
tracked animal then we upload to the
firestar database
in the collections for the with the
animal name
and then with our data okay
cool so that's a one-liner that just
creates the the record in
in the database i love that uh okay cool
the code looks uh like it's doing the
right thing i think but who knows
does it actually work in real life
million dollar question another one yes
let's deploy it
okay so we have our handy dandy
deploy script oh i love those deploy
scripts
so this is uh you could have typed some
typed out the full command but it's
often easier to have a deploy script
also this is kind of the script that you
would put at the end of your ci cd
pipeline right typically you wouldn't
type it in but
but your ci cd system would whenever
there's an update to the main
branch it would probably run something
like this
and i see you pulled it up what happens
here on these lines grant
yeah so we we're going to use g-cloud
functions deploy
providing our function name
and then we're going to specify our
runtime uh in this case we're using
node.js 10. um we we could provide like
python 37 or ruby
or even.net
and then we're going to specify a couple
parameters
for the trigger we're going to trigger
whenever um a
new file is uploaded to the critter
watchers
bucket and only trigger this one
whenever the
object is finally uploaded so finalize
means
the upload is done is that right yep
okay cool it looks uh in the terminal
there looks like
your deployment script finished uh how
now how do we exercise this code how do
we make it run to see if it actually
inserts something into firestore
well we can go and uh trigger the
the function just um
using the browser oh cool so you will
uh pretend to be to be a camera
yep so i mean
so let's go and add add some images
to our uh camera into our bucket and see
if our function works
great so i'm going to just drag and drop
a couple files uh-huh very good
and oops they all uploaded
very nice all right so now
for each of these four files our analyze
image function should have been
triggered once
and the analyze image inserts into
firestore so
if everything worked we should see four
records in firestore is that right
yes if we go
check our database
and refresh and go see
we should have some new records oh
i see alpaca dog gecko
can you make the font bigger grant yeah
let's go
thank you i can see all of our
our images are classified excellent
uh so alpaca there can we see what does
the alpaca photo look like
so yeah just in the photos url uh-huh
let's see
wild alpaca
so are we sure though that this is an
alpaca and not a llama
oh yeah i'm sure at least that's that's
what the tour guides told me in
oh really you took this picture yeah i
i took the photo and so i'm sure we have
the rights to it and
then we can use it and you can even
download it
ah excellent i i i will sleep a lot
better tonight knowing that we haven't
violated somebody's copyright
this is great also i feel really good
about
we have a tour guide and we have the
vision api both saying it's another
cocktail
and not a llama okay cool
so this uh event driven function now
works
uh creator watch can can use this uh all
the cameras will
call it implicitly when they upload
images that they're taking in the field
now critter watch is really happy with
this it just runs it's not a lot of code
but eventually they discovered that they
will
want to have a rest api in front of this
database
and the reason is that they will have
applications web applications
uh mobile applications where you can see
photos of like i want to see all the
alpacas that
has gone through my my backyard um
so they want to put that rest api in
front of the database
they also want to be able to do traffic
splitting
so canary deployments like they deploy a
new version of the rest api
and they want to be able to then send
only for example one percent or 10
of the traffic to the new version they
also
of course want to put their own domain
name in front of this rest api so it
would be like create a watch
api.com or something and finally
their cto has said that containers is
strategic
for them now again we have cloud
functions and we have cloud run
given these requirements what should
they use to build their
rest api grant good question mark
well looking at the selection grid it
looks like they should
probably use cloud run i mean they
could use cloud functions when people
say cloud functions is easier
but it doesn't support traffic splitting
or custom domains for example
so looking at the api rows
of the grid the checkbox boxes
clearly show that cloud run makes a lot
of sense
i mean we could use app engine but they
wanted containers so let's go with cloud
run
okay cloud run it is uh what would the
code look like for this api grant
now let's go to our code editor all
right
so we're looking at another index.js you
like node grant
right yep i love node
me too i'm happy you picked node uh all
right
so what's happening here this seems to
be a little more at the top of the file
than we saw in the previous example
yeah so whereas with cloud functions you
have to
just write your code and you don't worry
about your server as much
with the cloud run you have to
take care of everything like listening
to your
port and setting up a server yourself
i see so the express framework that is
a library for listening to http calls
that are coming in right yep and so we
go
and set up express here you set up an
app um listening to port 8080
and we're gonna also use the firestore
uh api
and so um all right
yep very good uh so there's a little
more setup there in the beginning than
for cloud functions it looks like
uh but then the real action starts on
line 11.
uh could you walk us through what
happens there on line 11 grant
sure so we uh whenever we receive a get
a request
to animals we'll go and take the animal
name
we'll find it in our firestore database
if we did find uh something
it's not empty then we're just going to
get the actual sighting
and return status success with the
sighting from the database
otherwise we're going to just say four
or four we couldn't find this animal
status failure and say the animal wasn't
found
okay and animal name up there on line 11
has a colon in front of it what does
that mean
yeah so this means it's a parameter for
the
url so it could be animal slash
fish or animal slash hummingbird
ah okay so this is okay uh so it's
you would uh put your animal name in
there got it uh all right
uh well i don't know about you grant but
i feel another million dollar question
they come up pretty often yes
would this work does it blend
let's try it out okay
so i'll just go
into our critter api
and go deploy ah you have another little
deploy script there
you really like those deploy scripts huh
pretty useful
yeah what does this one look like
so this one's a little bit more
complicated as you mentioned before
you have to set up your container
so so here on line three we're going to
run up
run gcloud build submit passing
a tag which is useful for just labeling
our container
at gcr.io and our project name
and then also passing our project okay
so that piece lines three four and five
they don't actually deploy the code uh
but
they build the container is that right
yeah they build the container with the
doctor file
um provided and it just
sets that little docker file um and
container ready to be deployed whenever
okay very good so it's not serving
traffic yet
um i assume that's what line seven and
onwards are all about
yep and so now uh once you have your
container it's all ready to go
then you can go deploy it to cloud run
so you just write
g cloud run deploy providing your
service name creator watch rest api
providing the image we just built from
before
yeah we're going to run on uh platform
managed rather than like kubernetes for
example
um and provide our region
we're going to allow anybody to access
this api with allow authenticated and
also just provider project again
okay very good uh so again this would
probably sit at an
end of a at the end of a ci cd pipeline
uh but we're running it interactively
here to to show how it works uh i wonder
uh is it done deploying now do you think
i think so it looks like oh yeah look at
that little link
how would we exercise this and see if it
actually works
yes let's go check out
uh the url so if we go
check for example animals slash
gecko okay animal slash gecko
oh there was a gecko sighting i guess
there was i guess there's a
gecko sighting oh is that a gecko
oh so cute now i agree
but my top question is do we actually
have the rights to this picture
oh yeah i took this picture
i took it myself it was oh
and in central america oh of geckos
there huh
what's up yeah they they're quite loud
during the night
okay cool and just to see that the other
case works as well let's
uh search for like slash animals slash
cat for example let's see what we get
cat ooh
didn't find any cats not found well that
is as expected
great okay so now
this is how you can build a rest api
with cloud run
now they wanted traffic splitting
uh so when they deploy a new version
only send a little traffic to that
how would they set that up with this
rest api
so good question so here we have our
cloud run service
and we can go into it
and under revisions
you can see the manage traffic button
ah and i also see the list of our
versions there it looks like the top
version is getting a hundred percent of
traffic is that right
yeah so so we're we're at the bleeding
edge
we're saying all the traffic hey
whatever
we just pushed to production let's have
all of our users go there
oh the most dangerous version all right
so now if we want to dial back the risk
a little bit and
send most of the traffic to the previous
version what would we do
so we can we can do the manage traffic
button
there's also of course the cli
let's say we probably only just want
like 10 percent
um of our traffic to go to the newest
version yeah that seems a lot safer
let's do that
so we can just press save there
and it's creating this new configuration
this new revision and background
pretty quick now only 10
of the traffic whenever you go to this
url we'll get to the latest revision ah
excellent very good and as you as you
say this can be done with the command
line interface so
this could also be at the end of a ci cd
pipeline for example
okay great so that's traffic splitting
canary deployments they can do that
the other thing they asked about was
custom domains
now they have this long url that we see
here that has a hash in it and things
like that
but they want like creatorwatchapi.com
for example
how would they put that in front of the
url
of the api yeah so
they'd use a custom domain so
could you walk me through that martin ah
yes let's see this
is uh if you click back service details
yeah exactly and then it's the
next to create service at the top there
uh this funny button i always forget
about it
and usually now we have blown up the the
font size really big usually it says
like custom domains on it but that was
taken out
and then we can add a domain mapping
here
and the domain mapping takes two things
of course what service
should accept uh url uh traffic coming
to this url
and then what domain uh should should
catch
this so of course here we would uh set
up
uh just as we do with any other service
like app engine
or anything else you would set up a
verified domain and
walk through the steps here in cloud
platform to verify the domain
and when you're done now your new custom
domain
points to this service
awesome that's a really cool feature
yeah yeah it's
it's very useful all right uh so
i think that explains it all uh
hopefully that's clear
uh so grant actually uh i have something
to deal with over here
uh could you wrap up this episode for us
please
yeah sure um well thanks for watching
please leave a comment down below um
this episode was actually
based of a comment so we like to read
all of your comments and
and please suggest maybe a topic for a
future episode
um wait wait are you getting this
i i just got a notification from my
creator watch camera
apparently there's some animal
i wonder if it's one of those pesky
little raccoons
getting in my trash again let me check
the camera
oh martin
[Music]
you